so as an architecture and design writer
you know the thing that really struck
out to me about burglary and what drew
me to it
is that burglary is it's it's very
specifically an architectural crime so
burglary cannot exist without the built
environment it's not the same thing as
theft in fact you can be a burglar for
your entire life and never steal
anything and you can also steal things
for your entire life and not be a
burglar so any felony or the conspiracy
or intention to commit one inside an
architectural space in which you don't
have permission to be can be legally
considered burglary and so that has a
lot of really interesting and strange
implications as I'll be discussing over
the next half hour so and as we can get
into with questions at the end which
would which we would encourage you to
have some of you I love talking about
this stuff but so I really wanted to
dive into that notion that burglary and
architecture were legally connected but
also very conceptually connected and so
the first thing I wanted to talk about
was is actually the title of the talk
was just the notion of breaking the
clothes and so what's fascinating about
burglary is that it even legally
redefines where architecture begins and
ends and so it may seem you know it's
even a kind of a I rollin joke in a lot
of architecture schools where you know
whether or not we truly understand the
difference between inside and outside
whether or not we actually can make that
distinction but what's interesting about
burglary is that it actually does call
that that distinction between inside and
outside into into into question and
that's this thing called the close which
is this invisible line wit that exists
surrounds objects and a kind of you know
I might describe it as a kind of legal
crystallography it's a series of
invisible planes that defines inside and
outside and so think about so a couple
examples here would be think about a
convertible car parked on the street
with its top down think about a house
with a screened-in porch where there are
no screens on the installed on the porch
that on a particular day think about
your own home or apartment but the
windows are open or the
front doors open there may not
physically be a surface that that
differentiates one side from another the
public world from the private world but
nonetheless there is a legally
recognizable surface called the clothes
and the clothes of course is not
clothing but the clothes is enclosing a
door or an enclosure that that maintains
that that that fiction of inside and
outside and so that might necessarily
might not necessarily sound particularly
interesting it's very abstract but
what's pretty shocking about this
actually is the extent to which burglary
can be attached to things based on
minuscule crossings of an invisible
barrier that basically only lawyers can
see so a good example of that was a case
where an individual came out to a home
and was threatening the homeowner the
threat in this case is a felony and as
the Senate individual did so he leaned
against the front of the house there was
a on the windowsill the window was open
and the tips of his fingers crossed the
invisible line from outside to inside in
tandem with threatening the homeowner
that was enough to get this guy nabbed
for burglary so the tips of his fingers
broke the clothes and that constituted
physical entrance into us into a space
you may recall actually an interesting
thing in New York City maybe three or
four years ago where as an art project
these two individuals replaced the
American flags with white flags like
surrender flags
it was interesting listening to the
police actually kind of you know grind
their teeth and fantasize about the
kinds of things they could charge these
guys with but one of them was burglary
well it's so interestingly enough it was
because of the fact that in order to get
to the top of the Brooklyn Bridge which
is obviously in 100% outside and any
layman's understanding of the Brooklyn
Bridge they had to go over a fence and
into a kind of fenced-in area that from
the point of view of the law could be
considered an internal space that they
broke into with the intention of
committing a crime of both vandalism and
trespassing and any other things they
wanted to throw and so that was an act
of burglary in plain air so you can
imagine in other words a whole series of
kind of malign architectural
interventions on private property here
in San Francisco or on corporate
property in a city like Manhattan where
small Incan almost imperceptible
additions to the facade of a building
could be used legally to entrap people
and burglary without realizing that
they've in fact stepped inside of
something so briefly again I just want
to mention that the other thing that
this does is that it also gives I kind
of compared to almost like an
augmentation spell so if you have done a
certain crime whether it's a violent
crime or a crime of drug possession or a
handgun or that kind of thing it's a
very good way to simply extend the
sentence that would otherwise have been
much shorter or to nab someone because
you couldn't get them for the crime they
were actually doing but you can get them
for burglary simply by dint of the fact
that it occurred within an architectural
space that they didn't have permission
to be in and so it's a very interesting
crime it's added on to things and has
that peculiar relationship to inside and
outside
[Music]